hi well i'm going to take over thank you
so much
pharah and thank you again intelligence
squared for inviting me to share this
session
so in the midst of this current moment
that we're living in at the intersection
of what one of our guests has called the
triple threat of
covert 19 white supremacy and economic
fragility
where does art and culture fit in why is
it important for the arts to engage with
and then fundamentally transform
particularly in the response to the
black lives matter movement
ah the art a society creates tells a
story of who we think we are
and who we want to be so to explore this
today we have two
incredible trailblazers from the arts
joining us
firstly we have idris elba he's an
a-list hollywood star an actor writer
and producer perhaps best known for his
styring roles in the wire and luther and
for playing nelson mandela in the film
mandela long walk to freedom he runs his
own production company green door
green door pictures which champions a
diversity of thought
and he's been a dj since his teens
collaborating with artists including fat
boy slim
and skepta and has played coachella in
2018
people magazine voted him sexiest man
alive as my mom would say
martial allah brother kwame kwei
awa is also with us today i'm super
excited to also welcome him artistic
director of the young vic theatre
were it not for the pandemic his
production of hamlet starring cush jumbo
and ruth nager would currently be
playing them before joining the young
vic
he was the artistic director of the
baltimore center stage and his
award-winning play elmina's kitchen
transferred from the national to to the
garrick theater in 2005.
his series of eight short films soon
gone and win rush chronicle
was shown on bbc four in 2019
so thank you both so much for joining us
today
and kwame i'm going to start with you
we've just heard that in the uk the
government has announced the reopening
of theaters on july the 4th
but they will not be able to stage live
performances which seems a relatively
important thing for a live performance
venue
given as you've called it the triple
threat of this moment
how are you feeling about where we are
right now
well how i'm feeling first of all is
that um i was waiting for you to
tell me or at least announce where i was
voted the sexiest person
in the world
but actually i i just gotta say and and
i would say that
in this room i did a quick check and i
think that you've got like
i don't know 80 000 followers on twitter
and it just got like two million so i'm
like the boy here i'm just gonna let you
know
that i got the most to prove in this
room um
but on a furious note um
and it's just no you know it's a very
hard time um
and i think you framed the question um
really well
that we can open the theaters and that's
just the legal thing
but we cannot perform we can't even have
a bar in there just yet until
until we get the go ahead from public
health england and the government
i think one of the hardest things about
being a gatekeeper about being an
artistic director of an institution
particularly in a place like london you
know in a
multi-cultural intellectual
and it's a soulful space in london and
uh and our artistic community
are soulful and spirited people and so
at this time while we're amid the triple
threat
my theater would be alive and buzzing
with
people wanting to put on art with
intellectuals wanting
to discuss with young people wanting to
come in and find out
how they can contribute using the weapon
of choice or their weapon of choice
art and so it's a really hard time to
not know
that um not know when i can put my art
back on on our stages and facilitate
that kind of discussion um
i'm a hard-wired optimist i believe that
that we are going to store the energy of
this time
and when we can open our doors again
the the power that's going to
explode on our stages and vibrate
through into our audiences
is going to be like nothing that we have
ever witnessed before
and that's just not my stage but across
the stages of great britain
idris i see you nodding do you does that
resonate
yeah very much i mean i'd almost you
know
hello yes been good to meet you as well
um but i'd almost
you know replace the word art with voice
you know how do we you know you take
away my art you take it with my voice
you take away my expression
you know in many different art forms you
take that away you
then you know there's no way i can
release what i'm thinking
how i'm feeling uh there's no way for
you to reflect on my art
on how you're feeling and what you're
thinking and that
is a pressure cooker for disaster in a
community in
in a culture in a in a place like london
in a place like england
where we um you know we're used to
sharing our voices
we're you know we're used to that you
know and
some of the biggest moments of change
or or outcry have come either through
our arts or through you know uprising
and that again is our voice so you know
i agree with kwame you know it's uh
and i also believe that you know when
when when we do get to a place like
kuami said
i think it will be a very explosive time
i think it will be a
a a a very expressionate
time um and by the way good and bad and
by good and bad i mean you know
what you're seeing at the moment is a
real uprising on
on on the negative side on the right
wing side on the on the you know people
that have extreme views
but that uprising is okay because we
need to let go of stuff
you know you you can't kill our voices
we have to be able to
to express ourselves you know and
on the topic of uprisings i mean call me
this is not your first
this is not your first rodeo this is not
your first uprising how do you think
this generation's display of resistance
is
different to what's come before oh i
think that's a magnificent question and
i would say
that idris and i um have known each
other for
many decades and so it wouldn't be
idris's first ride
through this uh uprising either and i
think
you know the uprisings of the 80s
um on the on the streets of brixton and
topstep and
nationwide the the back end of the 80s
the second wave
i would say looking at 2011
and that across the country i was in
baltimore in 2015
and when that uprising the first black
lives matter uprising really happened
and now here and so this is like
uprising number five
you know and it's quite fatiguing
if there is such a word that when my 15
year old son
says dad can i go to the march in
central london
amid the mortal threats that he's
coveted and when i say why
that he speaks about you know the knee
on my neck
from white oppression and structural
inequality
is is harder than
the threat of kobe and that when he said
and i'm now my generation is gonna fix
it and there's a connotation that that
my generation didn't and the generation
before did it
and history has a bigger razor history
forgets the things that
went before my generation in the 1980s
we stood on the backs of those who
marched from deptford into
central london about the death index of
of many young black teenagers
having said that i am magnificently
inspired
in particular by young black women at
this month
young black women have said we got you
black men
we know at this moment in time
that even though we are being killed too
that your mere
presence provokes an existential answer
which means
that you have to be destroyed and put
down
from amy cooper to george floyd
and what about black women done from
those who are leading black lives matter
both in the united states and here
our sisters have galvanized
our sisters have said brothers we see
you you are our fathers
and our uncles and our brothers and our
fathers
and we got you we can't take no more at
that
that's an old generation
thank you thank you dude but and so i'm
magnificently proud of the way that they
have galvanized
at the way that they have spoken truth
not just to power
but to a different kind of ear
and that's what that's what they have
created your generation right now
your generation has in my opinion have
created
a deeper listening now how long that
listening will last
for is also up to my generation
interested in our generation
and yours to hold hands and make sure
that we can find the way
to both be inside the house and outside
the house
to make the noise outside of the house
so that those
inside the house can whisper in the ears
of our colleagues and say you know what
what they're saying out there is truth
and you need to fix this house
idris you're inside the house right so
how does it
i mean how different is this moment of
listening do you think just building off
what calm you said and sorry to
sorry to cut you there kwame um
what what does the inside the house mean
so yes well
i mean perhaps perhaps this is and it's
a good question back at me
i take inside the house to be someone
who's made it within the system at the
moment and the way that the system
is currently set up and both of you have
managed to find a way through
a system that is not designed
necessarily for you to succeed
um and i'm really curious about how you
navigate
how you navigate a system that's not
built for you to succeed
succeeding despite all of that and what
you do when you get there
well look you know when someone says to
me you're in the house it makes me think
of you're a house negro which makes me
think that oh no sorry you're safe no
i'm not saying you meant that but it
does have the same connotations
that well you're doing good you're safe
inside
and you know from my perspective success
has not hurt negated racism for me you
know like
you know you asking me about racism
is like you know asking me about
you know how long have i been breathing
you understand it's like
the first time you have any
consciousness around your skin
is usually about racism less about
you know mommy telling me you've got
beautiful black skin and you're handsome
more about wait i'm different from him
and i'm also being treated different
from him
that's one of the first consciousness i
had as a child
so that stays with you regardless of
whether you become
you know successful or you beat the
system
you said despite i believe that we did
it in spite of that you know i mean we
we we you know in my opinion i teach my
children i have a six-year-old and an
18-year-old and i'm always saying just
lead by example
lead by example if you know you if
someone asks is the questioning to you
and you know the answer
don't wait for everybody else to put
their hands up so if you know the answer
lead by example
and in my case you know knowing the
answer was just getting
on with it you know getting on with it
and that is really
about you know how people are programmed
i'm programmed to chase my dreams
i'm programmed to let no man put me
under i'm programmed that way not
everyone is
and sometimes there is a knee on your
neck or there is a
a foot on your on your on your foot to
holding you back
100 but regardless of that the way i'm
wired is to just keep going
and what's happened is i named my
company green door because essentially
someone said it to me
the other days is because i want to
leave the door open for the next man
and the door is green haha pun get it
see what i did there
but you know yeah but essentially that
that's why green door is that because i
really do want to lead by example leave
the door open for the next man
i think we should uh always think about
looking forward
we can spend a lot of time talking about
where we've come from
we could talk about why we're here but
what we should be thinking about is
where we're going you know if you put
something nasty in your mouth
you're not thinking about keeping it
there and discovering why it's so nasty
you want to take it out and put
something good in your mouth and that
is how we evolve you know that's how we
grow so that's how that's how i've
approached it jasmine
i appreciate that and thank you um for
clarifying that because i
for two reasons one um because i think
sometimes we can make the mistake of
thinking racism is something we can
outperform
when that's never the case we can't
outwork
you know our blackness um and also
the fact that you would characterize it
as in spite
um i think is a is a nuanced difference
but it's really useful
um and important to put forward so thank
you i'm gonna come
i'm going to come back to you calm in a
sec but i'm also going to ask you
address about
your production company because i know
that you talk about this concept of
diversity of thought
and the reason that that twigged for me
was diversity of thought was also the
same
phrase that um the health minister
matt hancock used to erase or hide the
fact that there were no black people in
cabinet he said ah well we have
diversity of thought so i'm really
curious about how you
interpret diversity of thought i didn't
know that um well
look you know diversity of thought came
uh as a way of describing
how we uh think about and this is very
specific around
how we think about changing the ratio in
the film industry let's see some more
black and brown
women uh lgbt communities
in the storytelling process and how do
you do that you diversify
your thought as of how you process
stories you know
many filmmakers will tell you that uh uh
black brown filmmakers will tell you
they'll go to a commissioner
and the commissioner will compare their
story to what's there
what's come before what's similar
the diverse the diversification of
thought is
nowhere it's just here okay so that
was where that term came from we need to
diversify our thought in order to be
able to
re uh configure the film industry
so we can see a lot more culture
see a lot more of the spectrum that is
london the london
i grew up in so that's where that came
from um
and you know green door essentially
is a hub for me to sort of harness that
try and put it to practice
you know um and we're very proud of the
sort of track record thus far
you know from if i'm honest and i'll be
you know transparent as a
successful production company where you
know you're
trudging along carrying this big old
heavy rucksack
but from a point of view of opening the
door and diversify
diversifying i thought and how we uh
accept
and work with writers of the spectrum
we've really you know we we look at a
project
and if it doesn't tick those boxes we
tend not to just put it away
so that's how green door is i'm proud of
what we've done there um
and there's still so much more to go so
much more
work to do so much more sort of
sophistication of the device of
diversifying your full thought because
there's so many variables that keep
coming up and storytelling
challenges are so different now you know
once
time the holy grail was to work at
kwame's theatre and have a moment or at
the national
or on the big silver screen or the bbc
now you just have
a real chocolate box of places to put
your content and
thinking about that thought process is
really like you know it's a changing
it's always changing so um but
yeah i'm just going to jump sorry kwame
i see you nodding a lot there and i'm
going to bring in another thread which
is
um you know you're you're in the theater
world which is
especially in england very white and so
how do you
navigate creating work that is nuanced
and talking about the black experience
in nuanced ways
for a very white trustee board for a
very wide audience
and doing doing that work in a way that
has integrity yes um
in in in a myriad of fashions and
exactly
i think in the way that idris has spoken
about but by
by leading with neurodiversity
right like like ethnic diversity and
gender diversity is great but
neuro-diverse is really important
to be able to have people around you
who's thinking completely in utterly
different ways
to you and to the environment
so when i will go to my theater oh go i
was going to jump in actually so i'm
going to challenge both of you a little
bit on that because
bringing in people with different um
ways of thinking doesn't necessarily
reflect the fact that different people
come in the room with different levels
of power
different experiences and so on how do
you navigate for the fact that
you know this queer woman who's walked
into your room for example
um might not have the same amount of
power and leverage and even capacity to
bring to the table in the same way that
you know um i'm a white man who's gone
to oxford for example like how do you
navigate
all of the the different intersections
at that one table great i i would say
this i am not the colored version of the
thing that walks before me
i walk into my space as an african as a
diasporic african
that doesn't just mean that i'm there to
tick a box in terms of color
it means that the culture that i have to
create in my organization
has to fall to my right foot as a
diasporic
african if you'll excuse the football
analogy i don't know very much about
football
um and so the the the truth of the
matter is
is that if there's a queer brown woman
in my at my table
it's on me to make sure that i give her
enough space
to be her full self and the way i lead
my artistic meetings
and the way that my board allows me to
lead the theater is that both
neuro ethnic gender diversity is
tremendously important it's like idris
said
that before you can come to me you've
got to check
many of those boxes and you've got to
check those boxes
not because they're the leader but
because that's an integral part of you
when you sit at my table
intersectionality
needs to be part of your call or you
will not be at my table
when i run the theater from the inside i
say listen
i don't necessarily believe that every
decision should be made in a eurocentric
fashion
in an aristotelian like here is a
destination i mean here's the beginning
here's the destination we just beat
through the agenda we get to the end i
don't lead my building in that way
i leave my building in and this may be a
generality and i'm happy to stand by it
but i lead it in a way
that that leads with what i might call
female dramaturgy
the circular motion of thinking which is
actually the base of the way that
african music is created it goes round
and each time it goes round you add
another thing and you add another thing
and you add another thing and before you
know it
it goes boom and so and the oil comes up
in all different places in the
in in the sphere so your challenge is an
absolutely right
challenge but our challenge that's why
i'm so proud of idris
you know the first time i landed in the
states to take over my theater there i
went to my cousin's house i switched on
the tv
and it was idris man collecting an emmy
i went
not he's inside the house as he said as
a house of the house negro i went
here the journey traveled from east
london
to collecting that enemy that journey
traveled where i walked into my
rehearsal room
and the joke that i did for years is hi
i'm idris elba and everybody laughed
agreement oh that's now we know that
black brits exist
that was actually a change a seismic
change
in perception art and artist
everything in front of us is born of the
imagination
and so to understand that we have that
power that we can do that
by looking forward carrying the luggage
of our history
in each pocket and every part of us but
having our eyes
forward being intersectional and not
trying to
imitate a european arc
is part of the source
it's part of the world that i try to
create
and if i if i win i win not just for me
and if i fail well of course failure is
always just
oh that was beautiful thank you and just
before i
come to you idris um also i just want to
remind
people that are watching that if you
want to donate we're actually today
fundraising for the young vic
and so you've got a donate tab on the
right side of your screen um
so please go ahead and and do that
padres i saw you smiling a lot there and
nodding which i love
um and i also and i want to tease out
one of one of the threads that
choir presented which is this idea of
connecting back
to fundamentally different ways of
operating
um and i'm curious about how how your
kind of
uh roots if we can use that phrase
um has impacted the way that you do your
art
and and and also how does it
i mean why is it that you know if you're
a nigerian
rapper that you have to make it in the
west for people to think you've made it
like is that something that's changing
um yeah so listen the the first question
just to tackle that you know growing up
in kwame you might know this and jasmine
you too you know
my parents were of the school of thought
if you want to make it in this world you
have to be twice as good as the white
man
amen always said that to me you have to
be twice as good twice as good
and it became sort of like you know a
mini mantra in my head
no matter what i was doing i applied
whether my talent lied in football i
still applied in cricket you know
because i was always of that mindset and
when i approached ah
art came to me as a god's gift i'm so
thankful
i can i can really touch the
cornerstones of art with my heart
because i feel it i know it right
and it was easy to me so
i applied the same i need to be better i
need to be better i need to be better
and by the time that happens you start
acting no i started djing
i'm applying there i'm playing as an
actor i'm applying as a musician
you know before you know it you realize
you're quite multifaceted
like before you know i was decent at
football basketball
cricket and hockey you get it's because
i had that mindset
and the application of that in my art is
actually right now
the trend that everybody's multifaceted
you know they're realizing again to cut
through the the tape you have to have
your
fingers in many pies and i know i know
i've spoken about this with black men
before about
yo i'm good at certain things now that
you know i never thought would be useful
but i'm so glad i was paying attention
and when i'm holding my own in a room or
conversations and people look at me like
oh you know that because i've been
studying you know because
i've been reading i've been trying to
you know
and now i can apply those skills um
listen i think
the the the the the the plates have
shifted
in terms of if you're nigerian
that you need to be accepted in brooklyn
to be called a rapper that has shifted
those days are
over in fact i'd imagine it's becoming
the other way around
and i think one of the reasons for that
and nigeria is a great
example is uh that they believe
in themselves you know they believe in
themselves
they don't see a nollywood movie and
just criticize it because the lighting
or the continuity is rough
they believe in the intention they
believe that hey this story this folks
law
these actors are going to teach me
something
right and i'm going to get rich of
listening to that that belief system
is why nigeria is successful in its own
right why nollywood is the third biggest
okay and arguably people will say well
the quality is no good but you gotta
understand
the intention is so pure it's feeding a
generation
and they're going to get better and they
are getting better
nigerian music without a doubt afrobeat
killing it onto market space you know
so that's changed and i believe it's
something to do with
us nigerians believing in their own
you know instead of saying i'm gonna
take this guy's one
let me see what my brother is doing and
if he can do it
i can do it you get me and that is a
real that's a very helpful health
healthy cycle
you know friends can learn as well sorry
okay i'm sorry to jump in yes i i just
want to riff on that right
because when as just said when when when
we were young
i was a musician right and an actor and
when i'd walk into an acting space they
would never know that i was a musician
because you couldn't tell people
you had to separate your life into these
neat and
here we now live in a time when
everybody can be a splash artist
not just because they can but actually
because they
have to and is which means that actually
the thing that we were forced to do
which is twice your interest you were
lucky it was twice had 10 times bro
i now just say to my children that they
have to be twice better which is great
progress
but actually the box or or that place
that we were placed in by our parents
our brilliant
parents who made this country a warmer
place
the thing that they demanded of us that
we were twice as good
has now given us an advantage that
wherever we land in the world
we now know that we have a multiplicity
of skills
that we're not just gonna hustle on one
front but we're gonna hustle on many
fronts
and we don't have to be better than
nearly everybody else to even break
through
now that's coming home to roost and we
are landing wherever we land in the
world
and we are showing our value the
question that
that we keep shouting about in this
country is
britain don't look to america and just
look at its racism
look at how many glass ceilings you put
on us it made us
better but it also had a cost and has a
cost
on our spirits and our mental health and
we don't want that for our children
we want our children to have their eyes
straight ahead
not having to worry about any of the
other structural inequalities
that are trying to keep them down and i
tell you what we will solve the world's
problems
why because we have diversity of
thought in our dna because we have to
to survive 100
i feel like i'm you know at church slash
mosque
um so i guess i've got a cheeky question
um
for you both next we're an all black
panel here safe space shall we say
um what do you wish that you could say
uh like to all the folk in the
industries that you're in
and what's like something that perhaps
you wished you could have said when you
were coming up
or right now like unfiltered what is the
thing you
you want people to hear
um as i'm listen as i'm thinking about
this answer to be honest you know a lot
of my mind goes to things that i just
have
you know said to myself in the mirror
and cursed a man out you know i mean so
hard that there's spit on the mirror
but i'm gonna go away from that and in
actuality
if i you know religious or not but if
you if you take the concept of noah's
ark okay
and the ark is taking
the next generation forward the storm
has come
and it has blown people left right and
center
moving forward you you need to get on
the ark
if you feel post the storm that
you know some of the things that we all
turned a blind eye to that we all sort
of swept under the carpet
that we you know were too afraid to
outwardly speak up
about if you believe that that time is
still alive that time has passed
and the question is now will you be
stuck on the water
drowning with a lot of people who would
stay there or will you be on the ark
where people are just going to move
forward to greener grounds
you know and that's what i would say and
by the way again i'm an optimistic but
i'm also
i'm also realistic nothing's gonna
change overnight
that journey on the ark is a long
treacherous journey
it's a long one but we'll get there but
you have to be on it
to be there and that's what i would say
to to industry folks people that are in
position of power to change policy to
change
mindset to change their own company
policy
get on the boat don't stay in the storm
that's what i would say
i can't i love that it's going to be my
new mantra
get on the ark get on the boat mate yeah
on it
it's beautiful it does all work for you
get on the ark baby don't be on the
wrong side
of history um what
um and if somebody if somebody said to
your comment well what is
what is the up what does that mean for
me i like you you know
you know
i mean the ark for me right is the arc
of the long
arc of history it bends towards
justice
someone said to me you know how do we
bring down structural inequality
how do we bring down white supremacy if
you wish to call it that how often say
listen it's
it's you know it's the same as how do
you eat an elephant
one bite at a time but it's not just one
person
it's everybody biting it's everybody
eating
and there is that that's why the ark
metaphor
is so good we are amid the storm many
people think that the storms pass but
the storm is
still here after george floyd we just
saw another two people killed
the storm is too he is still here
when we walk into our work space if we
can there will still be discrimination
when we look at the codeword results
we're still seeing that
black and brown people are
disproportionately affected the storm
is still here you need to be on the
inside of the ark if you wish to survive
that is from white supremacy to
african ambition get on the ark
dress you give me something today
on that one now i've got one more
question uh for you just before we
take questions from the audience and
just a reminder if you're watching that
you can
ask questions so get them let get them
in they just
um i'm curious
what does what does when you know
we reach the end of that journey what
does that world look like paint me a
picture of
it does it look like black theaters and
and white theaters and brown theaters
does it look like
nobody really thinks about like what
what what does it look like
when we get it i mean you know just to
give it
sort of you know try and try and be
succinct about the answer you know
that that future looks like
kwame's son at 15 at my daughter at 18
you know that future is alive and well
you know
kwame and i talk about generations
because we've lived it
these kids haven't even lived it and
they talk about their generation
they they see themselves as a generation
we can call it x y whatever you want to
call it but they see themselves like
that
we didn't you know divide and rule we
got divided
we didn't see ourselves as a joint
generation they do
what does that mean is in the future you
know for me it feels like a place where
you know sexism uh
racism you know are are are
um ultimate disqualification
okay as as as kwame said if you
don't if you make it to the table when
you don't come with the x
amount of the stuff you won't be
at the table and i think if you imagine
a generation where
you know that is inbred into all
industry
okay it is inbred into education
into the health system where you don't
look around thinking you are being
treated any worse than the next man
that's what this looks like
when you go into uh to sell a film
you're going in there because your
generation of people
are looking at you knowing what we've
come through
and expecting your story to reflect it
not not that oh you know we we want you
to come in here and just sell us so that
we can make a lot of tv
no we want you to tell us something and
that's what i imagine and and that's
what i imagine
that the future will look like will feel
like that there's a general consensus
that hey
we are all of this generation we all
deserve a chance
let's give it let's do that you know
richer are going to always stay rich
paul is always going to stay poor that's
that's just a factor of life yeah
but the the the the reconfiguration of
how justice and equality is
it can be set is is is definitely
what success looks like to me
and my question my last question for you
before we go
over to the audience questions is you're
you're now in a position where you're a
gatekeeper
um and so you know the sort of like
steps that people can actually take
so what are the the folks watching what
are some
steps that they can leave this
conversation with to be like all right
this is you know if they're a
film director or a head of a theater
what do you want them to go out and do
i think he just said it you know um but
let me let me
frame it from my mouth and when the door
opens make sure you've got your luggage
with you
when so that when the plane goes to take
off you don't have to say i've got to go
home and pack
make sure you've got the thing i like
only do art
if you must not because you have to
but that you must because the rejection
for everybody in this is so much it's so
hard
it's so damaging to your spirit that
when you step into this arena step in
knowing that you've got the goods and
when you take the rejection i often you
know sometimes when i was a
younger writer i would write something
and it would be rejected and then i
would see something like it on the tv
and i'd go and people and i don't first
of all i'd be sad and then i'd go no
that means i got it if that broke
through
then i got it a friend of mine he's an
actor and his father was an actor
and uh he said dad give me a bit of
advice on how to navigate
as well and he said son there are a
thousand
reasons why you may not get an acting
job
just don't let your acting be one of
them
very nice all right i'm going to go to
the we've got a bunch of questions
coming through so the first question i'm
going to take
is from gabriella who says what are your
thoughts on diversity quotas do they
help
or are they like tokenism
i i'm going to jump in if i may i think
absolutely
i think there is a time when you just
have to say let's just do it
yes they absolutely help i don't care
what
quota let me into the door and a quota
did let me into the door
it's when i'm on the inside what i do
with it and i believe you let us in
we will multiply the next question
thank you kami um i'm going to give to
you idris
it's from olu and says do you think
there's an inherent fear of an all-black
cast in british film
tv and theater and if so what do we do
to change this
um i mean i wouldn't describe it as an
inherent
fear uh there's definitely
reservation uh and marginalization that
happens you know the
the quickest thing you say when you know
someone presents an all black cast is
whoa feels a little bit snish
a little bit that's the first thing you
hear okay
uh and yeah that may be derived from
fear but i wouldn't
describe it as fear what we do about
that
is we we tell our stories we have to
tell our stories
you look an all black cast means it's a
story about
this community this family
this building this junction okay
those stories are rich those stories
need to be told okay
we need to keep banging on the door and
bringing them forward
okay there will come a time when your
story's not
um um not taken because it's all black
but because it quite isn't deep enough
that's where we need to get right so in
my head
you know taking these stories into
commissioners
taking these stories into uh our
artistic
um directors you know
as aquami said with the analogy of make
sure that you come prepared make sure
it's good
make sure it's good make sure it's
relevant that's really important
not let's just have a black cast for the
sake of it
all right thank you make sure it's good
so kwame
we have a question from uh dupen and i
hope i pronounced that correctly i'm
really sorry if i didn't but as an avid
theater goer at least 40 times a year
and a person of color
it's noticeable that the audience is
especially in the theaters of the west
end
largely white what can be done to get a
more representative
audience in and often people say we need
more poc on stage but stories of stories
and i'm moved by firemen as much as i am
by hamilton um
first of all i want to big you up for
coming to the theater so much
thank you and and and i think there's a
couple of things
i i think you know we are
as as a species we are very tribal
and uh and so often
we like to see ourselves and when we see
ourselves
that seeing of ourselves is an
invitation to join
we actually as black people have had to
not do that
because of the lack of representation
for many years
we've had to be able to see ourselves in
other people
and that's widened our empathy it's
widened our
i'll actually decrease our sense of
tribalism
because we can go and see hamlet if that
work with a white actor
or we can go and see august wilson and
in jitney if that where we can do that
and so actually what
i think we have to make sure we do is
signal to audiences
that you are welcome into this space
you are welcome because you know there's
not an italian gangster movie
and i love me a gangster movie right but
there is a moment in that movie
when one of the gangsters says you know
sell the horrible drugs to the blacks
because they ain't got a soul
or telling about it ever against me and
what i have to do is go
i love this movie up to this point okay
i heard it now i've got to get back in
after that bit and
i do the subjective objective but why
because i like the job
and i think that's what we have to do as
theaters we have to continually say
you are welcome into this space this
space
is not a white space it doesn't matter
who's on the stage
and i think that we're doing that i
think we're beginning to see it across
london
an increase in diversity of audiences
not just because of who is on stage but
who's running the theaters
and what they're choosing to program
okay thank you um now i've got a another
question
um from an alexander um
that i'm gonna couch a little bit which
says
you say you admire black women but how
do you respond
when folks within the community feel
disappointed by some of your choices and
as black men
how do you show that you're equally
supportive
of black women or address these kind of
intersectional issues
um so so
correct just rephrase the first question
again for me because
i wasn't i wasn't sure how to answer
that
sure um i think it the question's
referring to
some of the choices that all the work
that you've worked on in the past
together
and i guess it's referring to
how do you as very prominent black men
in the arts and culture world
respond when other parts of your same
community like black women feel
disappointed
no sorry sorry i'm gonna
you know everyone has the right to be
disciplined
like everybody has the right to be proud
right and so whatever i do if i look at
my theater
i look at the overwhelming majority of
the of the work that's been on my stage
since i've been the artistic director
has been diverse the overwhelming
majority of the work
have been produced by women the
overwhelming majority of the work has
had black women in the court
probably not the overwhelming but
certainly majorities had black women at
the core
but i don't do it for the applause of
black women i do it because i'm my
mother's son
i do it because i'm my daughter's father
i don't do it for anybody else's
applause i'm not
i'm not opposing i'm not actually
signaling i'm doing what i do because i
think that's right and i can look at
myself in the mirror
and say sister if you were disappointed
in something that i did then i'm sorry i
hope that it was a sin of
omission and not commission and now that
i've heard you i'll try and
integrate that in my into my thinking i
would
like you to be proud of me but you don't
have to be
possibly your criticism will spur me to
greater things
but i am my mother's son
i will just just before you take the
next question just
attempt to answer that too i mean i'd
say the same you know i mean if
you know there's choices that i've made
as an actor that disappointed
um predominantly black women that breaks
my heart for sure for sure
and you know my intention would be to
okay let me see what i can do to to do
better
but i will tell you this that you know
if someone wants to ask me what i think
i'd say
well i you know disappointment is part
of my game i
disappoint many many people if i didn't
i would have fans everywhere i don't not
everybody loves me and that's a
part of my acceptance i accept that and
and so
you know for me i wouldn't answer that
question like hey
i'm gonna give you my reasoning as to my
choices
but you know what that's part of my game
i'm sorry you're disappointed
i appreciate you both answering that
question honestly
um the next question i have is from a
jason who says
a lot of black celebrities were called
out as not supporting black lives matter
on social media and accused of being
traitors to the fight
do you think they received this
condemnation due to their perceived
silence and how do you feel about
sort of celebrities and engagement with
issues like this on social media
like i think that celebrity politics is
very dangerous
and and it's become a real hotbed it's
become a real sort of topic at the
moment
and you know listen you know my i
probably am one of those
celebrities this gentleman's talking
about because i tend not to
overly send my views on twitter i don't
consider twitter a place where my
views on a subject should be you know
acknowledged celebrated or
you know disappoint people it's not the
forum it's social media
and i think people take it very very
seriously especially
in times like this uh for me uh
you know i i think that
if we are looking towards our
celebrities
for guidance at times like this when our
leaders are letting us down
then there is an issue of focus on that
point
you know for me yes i can use a platform
to amplify
things and i do but social media isn't
necessarily the forum
for it and i would say
you know i i love i love this generation
man and i love
that you have you know from easier in
2011
to today that we can use social media to
mobilize
and and and to advocate and it's
magnificent
and i was very proud of john boyega when
john
you know to to have to to put all that
he has
at risk by by speaking from his heart
in the way he did i wanted to cry i'd
literally sat in this chair watching it
on tv going
oh my god but also um
you know everybody does the thing that
they can do
and i don't need someone to virtue
signal by saying black lives matter
on a tweet or on any kind of social show
me your deeds
you don't know what's going on behind
the scene you don't know what movie
they're negotiating right now
that could actually put this right in
the middle of a discussion whether it
might not have been
you don't know we don't know so we can
look for the
virtue signaling and that's great and we
can and i don't mean that doesn't mean
that everybody who did it was
but certain people go to the media me
art is my weapon
if you want to see what i'm thinking
today look on my stage in a year's time
you'll see that because trauma
is best served at a distance
yeah trauma best serve at a distance
i'll remember that
um this is a question for uh
both of you i think um from a shekhar
bassey
and says how do i as a disabled
screenwriter
filmmaker actor break through the
independent filmmaking scene
or get through to bame run production
companies when there's a subconscious
bias towards the very nature of
disability
and the lack of assumption of ability
um and i wondered if you had a take on
that
um well i mean you know again it's about
being
in my opinion just you're gonna weather
the storm
we know the restrictions let's not talk
about the restrictions and let's find
the way through
yes you know let's let's be gravity
gravity
is your goal just fall towards it yes
um there needs to be massive uh
reconfiguration of that for that
especially
for people of disabilities
uh uh at greendale we stay very
conscious about it
some production companies we know do not
we know that
but it is around allowing that message
that
um not amplifying that
somehow within the industry um brother
you know send your scripts
in to myself and kwame if they're not
for us you'll get a letter to say
they're not for us
but don't give up at that junction
center the next man
you know um you know
please don't allow your disability to
and
your knowledge of how you are not
acknowledged
to stop you you gotta move forward
i love that thank you oh sorry are you
going to add something
would you say brilliant so a bit of a
more light-hearted one from
kenneth at the africa center what song
best
sums up for you the moment we're in
right now what is the anthem of the
moment for you
get up stand up come on you're right
[Laughter]
um wow that's a great it was gonna be a
bob marley and it was gonna be
um quick
industry i know you caught me but i'm
just gonna piggybank on that it's not
just the song it's the entire album
uprising and on twitter i put that
picture up of that album if you listen
to that
album made almost 30 years
to this time ago it is like
word for word accurate and relevant
so it would be that album big man africa
center yeah from uh
from back in the day soul to soul
awesome well i'm gonna have to play
after this i think um
so we've got a question from uh
lazana who says when are we going to see
a british version of hamilton
um i i i i will say we will never see a
british version of hamilton
um but we will absolutely see
uh in a multiplicity of places
um our truth may manifest
through the lens of history and
contemporaneous
rhythms we will absolutely see that it's
already happening
all right um there's another question
around castings
um which says do blind castings work
and that's from a derrick and i want to
kind of piggyback on that a little bit
um around the idea of should we be
casting
people in a colorblind way or not
or what's your take i'm sorry
if i may just jump in there um i think
sometimes
language in the english language is
brilliant in that way is that
that it can skirt the issue by and even
states the issue
there is no such thing as color blind
casting because we cannot walk into a
space
and not see color i know that many men
are not uh not as adept at color
identification as women
as they say but there is no such thing
as color color line casting
what there is is purposeful cast what
there is
is saying the best person for the gig
gets the gig
and i think that that ultimately when
you walk into a theatrical space and
this is where we have a great advantage
film and television can be linear
magnificent but linear if i'm in paris
you've got to tell me you've gotta show
me the eiffel tower or versions of right
but theater is an abstract art form if i
say i'm in paris just saying it means
you're there and then you do the work
for me that means a casting for me can i
can cast anywhere
and anything because it is a fantasy and
i'm not
color blind casting i'm unconsciously
saying
welcome to this neurodiverse space
where your abstract thinking aids your
experience
does not take away from your experience
idris do you have a take on uh i i do
but
i'm conscious of time but yes i i sort
of agree
um you know the the writing process is
where you know it is very key
to this conversation you know it's very
key i grew up in a time where
you know a black man was described as
the sporty type
the rugged type you know and they didn't
yeah and they would say
black sporty type right you know and
you're like what and
it's in the writing it's in the writing
when i get a script now
i don't look at the color
um i'm looking at you know if
there's you know you don't want to
misappropriate someone's culture
by casting you know sort of
short-sightedly right
but the writer if the writing is good
gives you those clues gives you that
that template to do what you need all
right we are as you say just
running low on time um so i'm going to
give you both
one last question each before we wrap up
um
and maybe i'll come to you kind of on
this one we've talked about how this
kind of
period of uncertainty this black lives
matter movement or moment
of moment of movement sorry is going to
bring about a new generation of artists
what do you think needs to be put into
place so that we capture this potential
and that's from gabriella um i i think
first of all we need a bailout from the
government so that the government
makes sure that that theatre um can
exist
the modern work with social distancing
the model doesn't work in the way it is
right now
we need to be able to reopen our
theaters as you said and
allow performance to happen we need a
generation of gatekeepers who are going
to come in
with diversity and neurodiversity
and intersectionality right at the core
and then we have to say recognize that
we are in the middle of a portal
and what we had before will never be
rebuilt and we don't quite know what
we're going to build
tomorrow but we're going to build better
and with that i think we'll be able to
seize the day carpe diem or even seize
tomorrow i don't know what the greek is
for tomorrow
and everything and create the art world
that we've been longing for hmm
all right address the the last question
that i have for you um
says i'm gonna take spin on it slightly
it says
what would you like to what advice would
you give to your younger self
but perhaps the question is what advice
would you give to a younger version of
yourself that was coming up today
um my advice would be um
you know stay focused and see the prize
the whole time um you know there's gonna
be
times where that prize is really hard to
get
just stay focused and get towards it
that's what my main
my main um uh advice would be and under
that in sub brackets i would be like
save your money okay
be smart with your money okay uh
be genuine with your friends okay like
make friends that you feel are gonna be
there for life
don't you know just latch onto anybody
and think they're going to do good by
you
all right be careful of that that's an
important one especially with your
rise as an actor as an actor uh
people tend to you your love the love
people have for you is amplified and
it's
fake sometimes so be be wary of that
um i would say
learn a different language learn a few
languages because
i didn't and any language i've learned
apart from my mom's creole from sierra
leone
i've had to learn in bite sizes for a
movie
lord do i wish i could like speak french
or speak in spanish
i would have jumped into so many
different markets as an actor
i would have been you know it would have
been a really door opener
for me um and the one thing i would say
to anybody that's coming up is man you
gotta enjoy it you've got to enjoy it
you gotta
love what you're doing you know even the
rainy days are gonna be
sucky but you gotta love what you're
doing that's the
like if i'm honest i took that advice as
a young man to myself
you know i i had many times when i
thought i'm just gonna give this up this
is not working for me
but i love it so much i mean i genuinely
love it i just this
i wouldn't do it i would do it if i
didn't get paid for it
so if you have that same feeling for
what you're doing
stick at it manny and it will pay off
for you
oh the buzz in this last hour
overflowing thank you both um kwame
and idris for sharing your time and your
wisdom
and your honesty your hope and your
optimism
you know in a time of a lot of change
um in a time of of great uncertainty and
a time of a lot of pain
i think for so many of us but also you
know we're getting on that boat right
yeah we're getting on the ark
i just want to say thank you as well you
you know
thank you for drawing out real questions
you know drawing out real themes thank
you for going deeper
uh in in this in this time and you know
you do it majestically and you should be
a beacon for of women
as well as men so well done thank you
i'm gonna go home and be like idris said
i did this majestically
all right i'm gonna hand over to pharah
now thank you both so much have a lovely